on the seventh day of counting the
ballots the major news networks have
finally called the Arizona governor's
race for
the Democrat
we all knew this was how it was going to
turn out we knew from the moment that
they dragged the count on past election
day the longer the ballot counting takes
the more likely the races are to go to
the Democrats coincidentally what are
the odds so in a race that involved more
than two and a half million votes just
about 20 000 ballots have determined
that Arizona's Secretary of State Katie
Hobbs who coincidentally was the
official in charge of this very election
will be the next governor of Arizona
over Kerry Lake who had been campaigning
specifically on rooting out corruption
in the electoral process
the national GOP seems ready happy even
to move on from Kerry Lake and from the
whole Maga movement Kerry Lake remains
defiant her her response on Twitter was
arizonans know BS when they see it love
her love her in any case Carrie Lakes
apparent loss was supposed to be the
final nail in the coffin of Maga and it
may well be
but Donald Trump seems to be launching
one last effort to keep his movement
alive and that announcement is scheduled
to take place down at Mar-A-Lago just
some hours from now I'm Michael nolsos
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Old School who
says running a Biden fetterman ticket
for 2024 would be a no-brainer
waka waka
that one got me then when I when I first
read that comment good job old school
just showed up before on the uh best
comment of the day and that one that was
pretty good and as our national policy
is increasingly led by people who don't
know what they're doing who don't have
the tightest grip on reality you are
going to want to make sure that your
assets are in things that are really
tangible which is why you got to check
out Birch gold right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 inflation continues to bedevil
our economy the daily wire reports that
in less than two years
inflation has soared from 1.4 percent to
8.6 as of May 2022 the price of gas was
up nearly 49 the price of meat poultry
and fish was up 14.2 percent and the
price of used cars was up 16 the current
administration's irresponsible spending
patterns including Biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar rescue plan continues to
exacerbate the problem now is not the
time to have all your money tied up in
the stock market don't let your savings
wither away hedge against inflation with
gold from Birch gold text Knowles
kw-l-e-s to 98 9898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on protecting
your savings with gold Birch gold is
giving out a free gold bar with any
Purchase made by December 22nd but you
must submit your claim by Black Friday
with almost 20 years of experience in
converting IRAs and 401ks into precious
metals IRAs Birch gold can help you too
don't sit around while the fed devalues
your hard-earned money text nulls to
98.90 a98 and learn how you can convert
at least part of your savings into a
precious metals Ira if you place an
order by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar text Knowles
Canada wlas298 9898
I have a lot of thoughts about this
Arizona election I have shared some of
them I have insinuated some of what I'm
thinking about this election but I'm not
you know I'm listen I'm on YouTube I'm
not really officially allowed to say
what I think about this election
so I'll let Marjorie Taylor green say
instead
we create a big opening with mail-in
ballots and absentee ballots that's a
giant opening for fraud and I believe in
safe elections and I think that's
something that every single voter wants
to see happen happen and you're hearing
it from people all over the country
right now it's it is completely absurd
that they are slowly counting ballots
out in districts like in California
Arizona and other states we look like
the laughing stock of the world there's
foreign there's other countries that do
it in one day and count all of their
ballots up and they get their elections
done I can't imagine why in the United
States of America we can't accomplish
this in one day and I think it looks
ridiculous preach it ladies she's
talking about 2020 and she's talking
about 2022 and and absolutely preach it
she's saying we're the laughing stock of
the world we can't conduct our own
elections and that's totally true I
remember Anton and Scalia made the same
point after the 2000 presidential
election which by the way did not hinge
on how to count the ballots it hinged on
how and if to recount the ballots we
actually got the ballot count pretty
quickly in 2000. what happened was Al
Gore dragged out recount after recount
after well what about the hanging Chads
well after well the Florida Supreme
Court said this but who cares let's take
it to the U.S Supreme Court and he just
dragged the whole thing out talk about
election denial or whatever they call it
now
Scalia said it's pathetic
we're supposed to be the world's
greatest democracy we can't even conduct
our own elections and now we can just
never get the results on Election night
now we we see articles that are that are
boosted on social media from all the
mainstream platforms that say here's why
it actually takes weeks to count the
ballots
uh because you're rigging it that's
that's the only reason why you can't use
covid as an excuse anymore last time
they said well because of this cough
that has been going on for a couple of
years now you know well I guess in the
2000 election just just about one year
now there's been this cough from China
that's why we have to change all the
election laws and get rid of all the
election Integrity protections but that
doesn't work anymore covet is over and
they're just doing it because it gives
the Democrats an unfair advantage and
very few people are willing to call that
out
people say where is the evidence
the rigging is the evidence where's the
evidence the fact that the libs have
changed all the rules and gotten rid of
so many of the protections that were put
in place specifically to preserve
election Integrity like election day
like all the poll Watchers like
suppressing widespread mail-in ballots
like voter ID like all of that the fact
that the libs are getting rid of all
those protections is prima fascia
evidence of fraud that's it and very few
even Republicans have the courage to
call that out
and Marge retailer green is one of the
people who is doing it which is why I
like that lady a lot of fancy people who
wear fancy neckties and consider
themselves part of the real sophisticate
set they don't want to be associated
with Marge retailer green because I
guess she said some kooky things in the
past and she's not very Posh and
clubbable
but Marjorie Taylor green is a much more
serious person
than Mitt Romney okay Marjorie Taylor
green is a much more serious person than
so many of these Stooges in the GOP
establishment who do absolutely nothing
other than turn a blind eye to Democrat
corruption and allow the liberal ruling
class to continue to wield an exercise
power okay
and she's calling it like she sees it
and so is Carrie Lake Carrie lake is not
just saying oh well
all right on day seven of the voting
count I I guess they got enough for
Katie Hobbs and that's that now I will
go quietly into the night no she's
saying This is BS I'm gonna fight this
nonsense as best I can
absolutely uh but between those two
choices
the really clubable nice Touch of Gray
fitted beautiful suit Mitt Romney set of
the GOP
who do nothing other than lose
and the
phytum tooth and nail kind of said who
are willing to call out collusion real
collusion between the Democrats and big
Tech and the bureaucracy and the news
media and the ones who maybe aren't
quite so sophisticated sounding but they
they have their priorities in order I'm
with them okay that's that's my said
now it's not all bad news uh the
Republicans though we've lost the Senate
though we've lost some important
governorships
NBC News even is projecting that the GOP
is poised to retake control of the house
now it's going to be a really narrow
margin according to the NBC News
projection the House of Representatives
will be 219 Republicans
216 Democrats
so all the Democrats will have to do is
pry away a few Republicans and then they
can push through their agenda because
then they'll have the Senate and then
they have the white house so they can
get done whatever they want to get done
that's not the kind of margin that you
want to see now if Republicans have
control of the house what's good is that
the Speaker of the House presumably
Kevin McCarthy or some Republican leader
maybe McCarthy will face a challenge
after this weak performance in the
midterms
at least the Speaker of the House can
refuse to take up certain bills he will
have certain procedural power to quash
some democrat uh priorities and one of
those priorities
that any Republican speaker should
should fight one of those priorities
that any Republicans in the Senate
should fight
is one of the most radical bills I have
ever seen
go through our Congress it is a bill to
radically redefine marriage
it is a bill to enshrine into law the
obergefell decision which was a
constitutionally Preposterous decision
to invent a new definition of marriage
and shoehorn it into the Constitution
somewhere
uh Chuck Schumer is now saying according
to CNN's Congressional correspondent
that he has got 60 votes to Ram this
bill through
don't forget the Senate still has a
filibuster so Schumer doesn't just need
a bare majority Schumer needs 60 votes
which means he needs Republicans to vote
to radically redefine marriage and to
punish people for opposing this insane
absolutely incoherent definition of
marriage that flies in the face of all
of civilized tradition every major
religion and human reason in the natural
law
I'll put this into no uncertain terms
because I I know that conservatives even
and and certainly Republicans are kind
of mixed on the issue of how to how to
define marriage but when it comes to
this bill any Republican who votes for
the radical redefinition of marriage
bill
should be expelled from the party
any Republican and I'm I'm just laying
this out there now so that the
Republicans understand that there
actually is still some opposition to
this that there are actually still some
people who are willing to defend the
actual definition of marriage that every
single human being on Earth including
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
believed up until about five minutes ago
because it is just a fact of reality and
no amount of semantic gamesmanship or
romantic poetry from the Supreme Court
can change it any Republican who who
supports this nonsense should be
expelled from the party and you these
Republicans are probably going to be
thinking well look if five of us
or six of us or ten of us support this
bill they're not going to be able to
primary all of us there's not going to
be the political will there's not going
to be enough money for it fair enough so
what I think we should make clear right
now is
the Republicans who support this bill
and there will be a few squishes I think
that conservatives who still understand
what conservatism means and what
marriage means we should pick one of
them we should pick the weakest one of
them the one who we can most
least expensively primary and kick out
of office and we should concert our
effort to remove that Republican okay so
I don't know who that Republican is
going to be is it going to be Mitt
Romney is it going to be some other
squish whoever it is we should pick that
person and make an example of that
person and we should turn all of our
political Firepower on that person to
remove him from office to send a message
that we we will not stand idly by well
the conservatives quote unquote squish
on everything that matters including the
fundamental political institution which
is the family which is marriage just so
that we can I don't know what maybe get
some tax cuts sometimes
for some gazillionaires in Silicon
Valley who hate our guts anyway
I don't think so we're not going to do
that all right that would be the death
of conservatism we're all going to die
someday that's why you need
a will that's why you need to check out
epic will right now head on over to
epicwell.com use promo code Knowles if
you are listening to this show odds are
that you care a lot about how your kids
are raised you understand that your
children look to you to Define their
whole perception of reality which is why
it is extremely important that you have
a will in place this is probably the
number one thing about making a will you
think a will is just about where your
money goes but that's not it I remember
when sweet little Lisa and I set up our
will we sat down and the biggest
question is who's going to raise our
kids now there's other stuff that you
gotta you gotta think about too who's
going to raise our kids how does the
money get set up if God forbid something
happens to us when do the kids get the
money what about things like Health Care
power of attorney to make sure that your
wishes are carried out you know what
about all of these questions that you
have got to think about okay well epic
will will make it super duper easy for
you go to epicwill.com right now use
promo code nulls Canada wles to save 10
percent on Epic Will's complete will
package you can set it up it does not
take a whole lot of time you save 10
percent you can get an early estate plan
starting at just 119 bucks and save that
10 right now epicwill.com promo code
Knowles you know there on this marriage
bill you'll sometimes hear people
say some Republicans or some
conservatives who are or even liberals
who are trying to catch us they'll say
wait I thought you were the party of
small government
I thought I thought Republicans are the
party of small government now you want
to define marriage okay first of all
Republicans are not the party of small
government we are not in theory the
party of small government and we are not
in practice the party of small
government the Republican party was
founded on big government the Republican
party was founded to abolish slavery
okay and the first Republican president
was Abraham Lincoln he was a big
government conservative he suspended
habeas corpus okay the guy was not small
government now you might say well that's
bad okay I'm just telling you the
history of the Republican party we have
had eight Republican presidents since
Calvin Coolidge not one of them has
shrunk the government
not one of them
not Eisenhower not Nixon not Jerry Ford
not the bushes not Reagan not Trump not
not one of them has shrunk the
government
you might say well that's bad okay I'm
just telling you the history of the
Republican party we are not the party of
small government we are not the party of
reducing the size and scope of
government sometimes we pretend that we
are on television but that's not
actually what the Republican Party does
and I don't even support small
government I don't think there can be a
small government a country of 330
million people that governs a global
Empire
I like government within its just limits
but that's a different thing
what what role does the government have
in marriage
well I don't know marriage is the
fundamental political institution so if
the state does not have some interest in
the fundamental political institution
then the state doesn't have an interest
in anything and then we're all
anarchists which we're not I'm not at
least I'm no Anarchist okay I think we
need
good rules we're going to have rules
we're going to have a society we're
going to have laws and so they should be
good rules and not rule rules that
punish good stuff and promote bad stuff
but quite the opposite which is what
you're seeing play out right now with
PornHub
PornHub is the largest most mainstream
porn company in the world it's owned by
a parent company called Mind geek
and mind geek is now being sued into
Oblivion and this is a really good thing
the parent company of PornHub is being
sued by a minor child's mother because
this porn website
allowed the dis allegedly allowed the
dissemination of videos and images of
her little son being sexually molested
by an Alabama man this is despite
warnings from the authorities to Pornhub
Pornhub still allowed this video to go
out there and so it's I mean it's so
sick it's so nauseating to think that
this is out there that it's legal
I think it's a kind of dubious legality
that PornHub is even allowed to exist
but it's tolerated at least by the law
enforcement authorities and that it's
making a lot of money
that's awful and so conservatives need
to support this being shut down any way
that we can
you'll they we're dealt a tough blows
some months ago when credit card
companies stopped doing business with
mind geek because of these kind of
allegations of child pornography and the
more libertarian-minded conservatives a
lot of them said no it's absolutely we
need to defend pornhub's right to spread
filth around the world and addict little
kids to pornography but the conservative
said okay good shut it down shut it down
what percentage of my mailbag is young
man writing into me saying they've got
sex problems because they were exposed
to porn when they were kids
a large percentage of it when people
come up to me at colleges and
universities that's often a a problem
that they will bring up
it's just it's just awful it's awful
obviously for the people being abused in
the movies it's awful for the people who
are being addicted to the smut it's
awful for society that we're tolerating
this at all and for what
for the right
of these perverts to exploit little
children to make an extra Buck there's
no right to that you don't have a right
to that at all
you whatever to there's a lot more wrong
with PornHub than the fact that there's
child pornography on it there's a lot
more in addition to that that is wrong
but if the child porn thing is what's
going to take him down fine by me use
whatever we can do speaking of
dubious aspect of our popular culture
and apparently pornographers maybe I
don't know I just one of my producers
just told me that this girl has done
some kind of porn and made a lot of
money doing it remember bad baby
bad baby spelled with two h's bad baby
she is the girl who went on one of the
daytime trash shows and said cash me
outside how about that remember that
catch me outside how about that and uh
she became kind of a meme and and famous
for this so bad baby has just posted a
new look
she was a kind of
average looking white girl
uh with kind of colorful hair and now
she's posted after some kind of cosmetic
or maybe surgical makeover with lots of
tan product and things on she looks kind
of like a black woman
and she's dyed her hair jet black and
her skin has been darkened and she's
just presenting herself as a black woman
and so the reason I bring this up is not
because I I follow oh and she her hair
was yet black I'm sorry her new image is
that it's platinum blonde in a very sort
of dyed
out of a can way and then her skin is
extremely dark and she just she's got
big
you know obviously surgically modified
lips and she seems to have had some some
surgeries anyway she she looks much more
like a black woman than she previously
did I bring it up
because
it tells you everything you need to know
about white privilege
if White Privilege existed
black people would pretend to be white
because that would give them a privilege
but that's not what's actually happening
what's actually happening is that white
women are pretending to be black
Rachel dollazal pretends to be black
because it gives her social privilege
Jessica Krug you remember Jessica Krug
she was an NYU professor she's just a
regular old Jewish lady she pretended
for her career that she was not Jewish
but black Jennifer Lynn Benton
Jennifer Lynn Benton is a regular old
white lady from Indiana
and she pretended to be black and she
she had roles in BLM and all sorts of
left-wing activism
so you got Rachel dolezal's what check
German and Swedish
Jessica Krug Jewish Jennifer Lynn Benton
I don't know she's just some kind of
generic combination of of whiteness
all pretending to be black even Sachin
Little Feather do you remember that
Sachin Little Feather was allegedly the
Native American whom Marlon Brando sent
up to receive his Oscar for him and give
a protest of the awful treatment of
Native Americans just came out she's not
Native American at all
she's just a Mexican lady her name's
Marie Cruz she has no connection
whatsoever to the Apache Indians
because there is no privilege in our
present culture associated with
whiteness
actually there's only disadvantage it's
harder to get into college it's harder
to get a job it's the you're the only
race that you're that it is not only
permitted but encouraged uh to to insult
in our culture
we are told that white people are the
only race that you can't be racist
against so yeah of course I'm not
surprised at all the bad baby wants to
look like a black lady okay it just
shows you how different
the popular perception of reality can be
from the reality itself another great
example of this
Alex Jones
Alex Jones this is a story I meant to
get to it at the end of last week Alice
Jones was just ordered to pay another
half billion dollars to the families of
the uh kids who were killed in Sandy
Hook Elementary School
so
Alex Jones had already been ordered to
pay almost a billion dollars then there
was another uh lawsuit that demanded
that he pay 2.75 trillion dollars that's
the GDP of many countries and then
he in fact it was the GDP of the United
States not all that long ago and now
they're they're ordering him to pay
another half billion it's going to be 10
gazillion dollars by the time that
they're through
not uh I'm not I'm not defending Alex
Jones okay Alex Jones he might be the
worst guy in the world I don't I don't
know Alex Jones
but what he did the thing that they're
making him pay all that money for
essentially was get a story wrong on the
air
Alex Jones didn't kill anybody
Alex Jones he just said things on the
air that weren't true
the New York Times has gotten a lot of
stories wrong
New York Times got stories wrong that
helped lead to the Iraq War
New York Times has gotten stories wrong
that led to the Russia collusion hoax
plenty of people have gotten lots of
stories wrong
the way that the establishment media
reported on the George Floyd story led
to led to months and months of riots and
arson and looting and dozens of deaths
none of them are ever gonna have to pay
one penny because they've got the power
and what we're told in this in in our
silly absurd culture is that people like
Alex Jones they've got all the power and
we go after and we're speaking truth to
power we're taking stuff away from the
man Alex Jones has no power at all
he's just an eccentric guy who sometimes
takes his shirt off on air with a
microphone in Texas and they're going to
take that microphone away from him if
they can
the perception of power in the United
States and the way that our political
system works is very different from the
reality
very very in America you basically can
never be held to account for libel or
defamation it's very very difficult
the libs will never be held to account
for any of that
Alex Jones will the the right wing
people certainly will
you think Alex Jones is bad in the way
that he talks about school shootings in
particular wait until you hear about how
the Washington Post talks about
school shootings which we will get to in
one second only after I tell you about
the absolute best meet around today good
ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles due to
a shrinking herd beef prices are
expected to rise another 15 in 2023.
today's prices are going to seem cheap
in just a few months Supply will
continue to become more and more scarce
that is why I subscribe and I recommend
you subscribe to good ranchers as
grocery store meat prices rise good
ranchers inflation proofs your grocery
bill by locking in your price for the
life of your subscription how do they do
this I have no idea but it is insane and
if that's not enough to convince you you
can take advantage of their Black Friday
offer which is going on right now get
two 12-ounce Black Angus New York strip
steaks and two pasture-raised chicken
breasts free with any order when you use
code Knowles while you can't control gas
prices or mortgage rates you can avoid
meat inflation with a subscription to
good Ranchers go to goodranchers.com use
code Knolls at checkout for this special
offer that is goodranchers.com code
Knowles for two Black Angus New York
strip steaks and pasture-raised chicken
breasts free with your order good
ranchers American Meat delivered Alex
Jones needs to pay trillions of dollars
gazillions of dollars because of the
irresponsible way that he talked about a
school shooting
okay when are we going to apply that
standard to The Washington Post
here is here is how the Washington Post
reported on a shooting at UVA
they said
that uh
the shooter at UVA was had a troubled
childhood but later flourished
a troubled
childhood
but then
flourished
Christopher Darnell Jones Jr 22 years
old is charged with killing three and
injuring two others at the University of
Virginia 22 year old killed three
football players critically injured one
other then the other one was in the
hospital as well and it's basically a
puff piece on this guy oh you know he
was a good kid oh well
it was too bad he
you know he never kids would pick on him
when he was a kid you know he got
bullied he was insulted isn't that he
had he had a tough childhood but then he
flourished and then he murdered three
people
is an auster religious
student at UVA
that's that's how the Washington Post
talks about
murderers and Terror and Muslim
terrorists and all sorts of things
that gets a complete pass
Alex Jones gets a story right in the air
trillions and trillions of dollars
it's it's not to quote Adrian vermeul
the Harvard law professor when we when
we see this
absolute sort of double standard
it's not that it's hypocrisy it's
hierarchy
it's just there's just one set of rules
for the Liberals there's one set of
rules for the conservatives
speaking of troubled childhoods
Nick Cannon
now has 11 children with six women and a
12th child on the way and there was a
column in the daily Wire by Joe curl and
it said Nick Cannon I think it was by
Joe and it said Nick Cannon is the worst
role model ever and I have to correct
Joe a little bit here I agree
Nick Cannon is a terrible role model
but he's not the worst role model ever
to Nick Cannon's Credit in our abortive
culture
at least he lets his children live
I mean that sincerely
we live in a culture that at least
before the Dobbs decision killed 850 000
babies a year
so Nick Cannon is being very
irresponsible and there's no way that he
can be a proper father to all of these
children and these children are not all
going to grow up in the home with Nick
Cannon and they're going to miss out on
a lot of daddy time and they're going to
have a very skewed understanding of
marriage and the relations between men
and women that's all true that's really
unfortunate
at least he didn't kill him
Nick Cannon is more responsible than
many many parents out there today
who drive to the Planned Parenthood and
kill their kids
many many parents you think in New York
especially when we're talking about
black babies more black babies are are
aborted in New York than born
so you want to knock Nick Cannon
absolutely yeah the guy he really needs
to shape up he needs to act like a man
he needs to stop uh disrespecting the
institution of marriage and he needs to
be a better father yeah that's true
at least he didn't kill them the Nick
Cannon stuff by the way
is
becoming mainstream I mean you're you're
now seeing report after report weird
social media video after weird social
media video
about how marriage is
or giving way in a culture that has
abandoned the meaning of marriage
to polycules
so
this is our polycule
this is everybody okay
um we also have two kids but we don't
show them on tick tock
Okay so
me and Kyle have been together for eight
years been probably the whole time okay
me and Kyle are in a Triad with kit
we
have been together three of us for three
years we have one child together
and she's five
oh we don't show the kids on Tick Tock
though okay so me and Kyle and me Kyle
and kit were tried okay
okay
now
me and Sam
and kit
and Katie
met around the same time I started
dating Sam and kit started dating Katie
around the same time my dogs are going
crazy
Okay so
I started dating Sam kit started dating
Katie and then
um just about a little over a month ago
we moved everyone in together so
everyone lives in the same house now we
all live together
it would be funny
except for the kids the kids thing makes
it not funny
because it this is how this poor kid is
going to grow up multiple kids I guess
imagine that someday even when the kid
has grown up hey how'd your parents meet
how much how much time do you have
well kit met Kitty and and then Kitty
met Davey and then Davey had a
relationship with Philip and then
that's not the sort of thing you want to
be telling your grandkids that's not a
dignified way to live
it's weirder than the Nick Cannon stuff
frankly Nick Cannon is just pretending
that he's some you know Old Testament
Wayward King who's got a harem of women
multiple wives and
they're all obviously aware of one
another it's not good but it's got It's
a little bit more traditional than this
nonsense and by the way Society broadly
condemns what Nick Cannon is doing but
the society is largely encouraging what
these weirdos are doing because these
weirdos are able to wrap their their
perversions and their base desires up in
the rainbow flag Nick Cannon can't do
that Nick Cannon in many ways seems just
like an emblem of the patriarchy whereas
these people when they say yeah I'm
dating three people in my household and
I've got a kid with one of them and then
the other one's got a kid with this one
and then we got three dudes over there
in the corner oh Love Is Love Love Is
Love don't don't yuck my yum you know
come on man we're all just be tolerant
just be understanding and then in our
insane culture we've got to say wow
you're right I just hadn't thought about
it that way you're right you're in a
polycule man that's cool and by the way
at when we take away the meaning of
marriage
what is to say that marriage won't soon
come to Define this there's no limiting
principle on it whatsoever
I've got I've got the language here by
the way from the marriage bill
the language the marriage bill will
allegedly protect all religious liberty
and conscious protections under the
Constitution or federal law
and it will confirm that non-profit
religious organizations will not be
required to provide services facilities
or Goods for the solemnization or
celebration of a marriage okay now
notice that right here by the way I say
a non-profit religious organization will
not be required to get along with with
the new definition of marriage with gay
marriage what about businesses they're
throwing uh poor Jack Phillips under the
bus they're throwing masterpiece cake
shop under the bus they're saying
private companies and private artists
will have to participate in gay
marriages even if it violates their
religious beliefs religious Christians
and Jews and Muslims you're going to
have to participate in gay marriages now
if you don't want us to take your
business away from you
and then it says guarantees that this
bill may not be used to deny or alter
any benefit Rider status to any person
or entity blah blah blah blah blah oh
and then oh here we go
it makes clear that the bill does not
require or authorize the federal
government to recognize polygamous
marriages
yet
why not first of all how pathetic is
this this is what conservatism means now
hey look
I'm I'm totally fine with radically
redefining the Bedrock social
institution uh
but polygamy is too far that's where I
draw the line okay I'm listen I'm a
conservative I'm going to draw the line
listen I'm totally fine with normalizing
all sorts of sexual deviancy but I draw
the line at pedophilia for kids under
eight
okay well listen I'm a conservative I
draw the line at kids under seven
they've already done this with the sex
surgery it used to be no weird
transgender surgery because that's
disordered and we don't encourage people
to mutilate themselves now it's okay but
not until they turn 18. okay but not
until they turn 16. okay but not until
they turn 12. now the best law on this
in the country is from Ron DeSantis in
Florida and it says you can't trans the
kids until third grade
laughs
up up until third grade so starting in
fourth grade that's when they can be
indoctrinated into LGBT and by the way
it's the best law in the country
this is the most conservative law we've
got
and they've actually done okay but only
once you turn nine
I said my friend Vivek ramaswamy dubbed
it the wait till eight Bill and that's
where it's going so and there's no
reason to believe that this marriage law
will actually
prohibit polygamy for very long because
why would it
the argument for the real meaning of
marriage is that marriage is in its very
nature the union of one man and one
woman for the sake of the generation and
education of children that's just what
it is ontologically that's what it is
the argument for redefining marriage is
Love Is Love man and Anthony Kennedy is
there on Supreme Court he's like
we got a right to intimacy
you know man and it's like this is the
dawning of the age of Aquarius right so
if that's the argument for him just love
his love and Whoever likes each other
they can just say that they're married
how on Earth could you possibly
prohibit polygamy from that definition
I would violate the the very premise of
the redefinition
so get get ready for a polycule near you
you know last year we launched Our Daily
News podcast morning wire in this short
period of time it's become one of the
top news podcasts new episodes are
available every morning seven days a
week and they cover stories other media
Outlets won't touch so check out
morningwire on daily wire plus Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts
speaking of mental illness
horrible terrifying news coming out of
Canada and Canada is usually at the
avant-garde here America's top hat is
usually just a few steps ahead of where
we are headed so you've got to be
prepared for this to to come to the
United States we got to fight a tooth
and nail Canada is now
encouraging mentally ill people to kill
themselves uh Canada has just passed
and assisted suicide right the Canadian
Supreme Court discovered some right to
kill yourself of course there is no
right to kill yourself because there's
no right to do wrong and and killing
oneself is a is a grave grave sin and a
violation of the law of
self-preservation and it's just
absolutely no bueno uh but one one of
the arguments against assisted suicide
even the softest Arguments for it well
what if someone is an intense pain and
they've got a fatal illness terminal
illness that they're certainly going to
die from very soon don't you think it's
all right to just kind of up the drugs
and kill them
and I don't think that that's right at
all but that that argument works on a
lot of people then one of the arguments
against that is well it's a slippery
slope it's a very slippery slope and
pretty soon it's not just going to be
those terminally ill cancer patients on
the brink of death in intense pain who
are opting for doctor-assisted suicide
pretty soon it's going to be people who
are younger who are a little healthier
who are depressed who have mental
illness who are poor and now you're
seeing this play out right now in Canada
afraid to die who isn't
yeah amen it it uh
Amir farsood has applied for medically
assisted dying known as maid he lives in
constant Agony due to a back injury but
has started the process for end of life
because his rooming house is up for sale
and he can't find anywhere else to live
that he can afford he barely survives on
Ontario Disability support payments
which are just over twelve hundred
dollars a month he doesn't want to die
but being homeless is not an option I
know in my present health condition I
wouldn't survive It Anyway farsood meets
the criteria for made physical suffering
due to disability that cannot be
relieved his doctor who knows farsoud's
real reason for maid is his fear of
being homeless signed off on the
application in August farsood needs a
second to do the same there's a 90-day
waiting period he believes he could
potentially access made in about a month
I don't wish to be dead
um even with the pain even with the meds
um I still want to be here
only the most evil society would
tolerate this
and encourage this I mean this this is
as evil as it gets
we we talk about the Nazis you know we
invoke the Nazis in every single
historical comparison that anyone makes
because they don't have any historical
frame of reference
telling our most vulnerable people
killing off our most vulnerable people
that is that is whatever you accuse the
Nazis of that is that is it that is it
we are the baddies if we do that
we are as bad as it
can possibly get
if we do this
we're already pretty bad we kill 850 000
babies a year here in the United States
and then on top of that we're going to
kill our elderly our poor elderly if
you've ever had an aging relative
you know that at when it comes to later
stages of life
people feel they're a burden on their
families people feel there's a big cost
they need to be taken care of a lot more
they get depressed
I'm sure if this were an option many
many people out of a feeling of Despair
and guilt for putting their family
through some difficulty would take this
it's not as though if you legalize made
that's the new euphemism they're calling
it it's just assisted suicide
which which is just suicide it's suicide
but but it's even more evil because it's
got the complicity of the public health
establishment
complete violation of the Hippocratic
oath and of sort of basic tenets of of
good political communities
if you legalize this stuff it's not that
you're just going to get a few Fringe
cases of people who are really thinking
rationally and who just really have made
a calculated serious decision to kill
themselves
it's going to spread like wildfire
it's going to be every old granny who
feels that she's just a burden to her
family she's going to do it she's going
to feel pressured to do it every
mentally ill person in a fit of insanity
is going to do it every poor person who
doesn't want to live on the street but
can't afford to to make ends meet
is going to do it
every depressed person teenagers
children are doing this right now in
Europe in the Netherlands
Belgium
it's gonna it's going to spread like
wild and it is so it is the most evil
thing I can think of
this sort of thing
and the fact that you heard that doctor
signed off on it
the doctor knew that the man no doctor
should sign off on this ever if a doctor
signs off on assisted suicide he should
have his license revoked
violated the Hippocratic Oath but
the doctor knows that this guy's just
killing himself because he fears poverty
and homelessness and instead of saying
hey
I'm going to refer you to this agency
that's going to find you a home instead
of saying hey here's a check I'm a
doctor I make decent amount of money
actually with Canada socialist
Healthcare probably not but someone's
saying hey here I don't have much but
here's what money I can give you hey
don't kill yourself here's money to pay
rent instead of doing that like a decent
human being would do he says okay here
you go kill yourself and you got you got
to wait 90 days I'm sorry but then bye
see ya
doctor I don't want to die but I feel I
I don't have options okay then die just
go die go kill yourself
but we're the good guys right we're the
good guys we're not like those bad guys
you know it's amazing the moral preening
you hear from us in the West
oh okay at least we're not like Putin
Putin's a bad guy we're the good guy at
least we're not like Xi Jinping
Xi Jinping He's the bad guy
we are slaughtering babies and telling
the the poor people to kill themselves
rather than giving them alms
it's as evil as can be
and it's The Logical conclusion of
individualism by the way that's the
other thing this is why we're not immune
to it this is why even the right kind of
goes along with this sometimes because
yes the end of leftism is suicide yeah
we know that we are yes we ex we
understand that that is what leftism is
about is just destroying everything
burning it all to the ground but it's
it's the end of individualism true there
are a lot of people on the right
who accept the very liberal premises of
individualism the idea that I own my
body that I'm answerable only to me I
can do whatever I have a natural
individual right to do whatever the hell
I want especially with my own body you
don't that's not conservative that has
no basis in the
proper Western tradition
that is an outgrowth of liberalism and
it's not true
it's not true you
don't choose to be born into this world
you shouldn't choose to come out of this
world you are not accountable only to
yourself
you have obligations to your family to
your community and ultimately to your
God but we have a new moral standard
here in the West
and this is being represented in our
symbols the USA has just redesigned its
soccer Logo USA has a soccer team
apparently news to me I can't say I
follow it all that closely but the USA
has a soccer team and the USA now
they're about to play some soccer match
in the Middle East
and they've redesigned their logo the
logo is no longer red white and blue
the logo is the rainbow
it's the gay the gay pride flag
and you can see this on their larger
logo it says one nation
USA gay pride flag doesn't say one
nation under God they've clearly gotten
rid of that that reference one nation
but not with the SIM the traditional
symbol of our nation which is the red
white and blue it's no it's the rainbow
flag
because the rainbow flag is in many ways
the new American flag
I promise you the Liberals in this
country identify much more closely with
the rainbow flag than they do with the
American flag with the Stars and Stripes
the rainbow flag is the symbol not of
the traditional American Nation but of
the American Empire
that's why we fly Pride Flags in
Afghanistan that's why we fly Pride
flags at the Vatican that's why we do it
as a statement of American Empire also
because the pride flag
connotes Universal values
the American flag the traditional
American flag is a flag of a Nation it
says this is what our nation is about
and we're going to be a shining city on
a hill
we're going to be a beacon of freedom to
the world but this is for us
the pride flag is for everybody the
pride flag is just to conquer everybody
and to say that that these new values
that we have enshrined uh in this case
of sexual
uh eccentricity are they're for
everybody and actually you you have to
accept them the reason they're doing
this in the Middle East is because the
Middle East has a different much more
traditional view of these sexual matters
and so the the United States through the
soccer team are saying no you you will
adopt our views we're going to go in
there if you don't allow for the sexual
Revolution to flourish we're going to go
in there we're going to impose it on you
and we've done that many many times
because that's the flag of our Empire
so who's going to leave this Empire
that's the big question for tonight
Donald Trump has announced that he's got
a big announcement perhaps one of the
most historic announcements in American
history
that's going to be at Mar-A-Lago I will
be covering that tonight as well so be
sure to tune in I'm very excited for it
there's some tough news for Trump though
there's a new poll out of Club for
Growth it shows that Ron DeSantis
is not only gaining on Trump but he's
actually up on Trump in four key States
this is a poll conducted November 11th
through the 13th this is after the
midterm election shows that DeSantis is
up he's beating Trump in New Hampshire
Iowa Georgia and Florida
now you might say well I don't know if I
trust this poll or I don't know maybe
the club prefers DeSantis to Trump or
the polls always are they're wrong about
everything
if you're Donald Trump you're going to
be worried about this poll because right
now Trump is the top of the pack in the
GOP at least he has been for the past
two years but things can change very
very quickly in politics and I suspect
this speech tonight is about stopping
that momentum for DeSantis turning it
all around but we'll have to wait to see
we know that the only thing that we can
expect from the Donald
is the unexpected
today we will be discovering all sorts
of new genders on tick tock
I usually interview people on on
Tuesdays but you know listen today today
is all about Trump's announcement we're
going to be talking later on for that so
I figured we needed to mix it up a
little bit get some open our minds on
these questions of gender the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]